everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
going over Rubenstein's a mortal game
this is the keeper Rubenstein the Polish
Grandmaster from the early 1900's widely
regarded as one of the strongest chess
players never to win the World
Championship part of thats due to bad
luck in 1914 at the top of his game he
was set to face Lasker for the World
Championship that event was cancelled
due to World War 1 starting few years
prior to that 1907 faced off against
another Polish chess master door drop
Louie that is the game we're gonna be
going over today two of the strongest
Polish chess players at the time I
flipped the board since Akiba Rubinstein
is gonna be playing the black pieces so
we'll go ahead and start with d4 d5 a
Knight f3 pawn e6 III and pawn to a c5
and after c-4 this is the tirage opening
the symmetrical variation as you can see
this is looking like the Queens gambit
declined line after Knight to c6 Knight
c3 and Knight to f6 you can see both
sides have the exact same setup and this
is where one side decides to go ahead
and exchange the material we do you see
the pawn take here on c5 the bishop
recapture so this is always a good way
to recapture gets your dark squared
Bishop involved into the game this is
now attacking this long diagonal right
here controlling those dark squares now
pawn to a3 this is stopping the knight
coming to a b4 or even at the bishop
coming down to before pinning down the
knight to the king also opens up the
door if rather he wants to push on the
Queen side has a nice little palm
structure could play pawn to b4 later on
play pawn to c5 make things difficult
for Rubinstein Akiba decides to do
similar move place pawn to a6 stopping
the threat of the knight coming to b5
then b4 pushing the bishop back Bishop
has a couple move some players tend to
go forward
Bishop to a7 trying to still control
this long diagonal Bobby Fischer used to
do that quite often
Akiba decides to go ahead and bring the
bishop to d6 wants to still keep that
very centralized in at the game Bishop
to b2 soffietta and the bishop here
trying to attack this long dark square
diagonal and then we have castle on at
the king side and then Queen to d2 now
since all the pawns are pushed forward
on the Queen side it's still gonna be
castling on the King side of the board
thought we may see the bishop coming to
the game first castle but we do see
Queen to d2 now Queen to e7 and then
Bishop to d3 did have the option since
the Queen and the knight here are both
attacking at the square here to take
maybe there's recapture Knight takes
Knight takes here Queen takes you could
see rook to d8 preparing for discovered
attack once the bishop moves maybe Queen
comes back here to b3 decided to look at
this position and a George said no
that's not exactly what I'm looking to
do here so while he did have that option
decide to go ahead and play Bishop to d3
now the pawn takes and then the bishop
takes here on a c4 so it is opening up
at the board state a little bit here
pawn to b4 attacking the bishop the
bishop comes back to d3 and rook to d8
this is a open file here so getting the
rooks involved into the game that can
control a lot more of the game when they
are on these open files or sent me up
and followed when there's only one pawn
here they just tend to do much better
especially in the center of the board
Queen to e2 wants to make sure that
there's no shenanigans with the
discovered attack once the bishop moves
if the bishop was not here that would be
attacking the Queen here on a d2 so once
to get that out of the way and then
Bishop to b7 so we have White's
eyeing down both of the bishops on the
King side for black and we have
Rubenstein over here eyeing both of his
bishops here on a d6 and d7 at the King
for white so it does look like we could
have some fireworks as both sides start
to line up and attack on their opponents
kingside castle on the Kings side and
then Knight to e5 positioning his pieces
over to the king side also opening up
the door for this LightSquared bishop to
really start to attack his opponent we
do see an exchange on the board and then
pawn to f4 and this is where things
start to get pretty interesting because
this does open up for a strong attack
the Rubicon Rubenstein can start to have
there's a backward pawn here on e3 and
there's a little bit of room in front of
the King on the white side of the board
the bishop comes back to a c7 and then
pawn to e4 and this definitely opens
things up black was already gonna be
coming here to b6 probably before his
opponent played pawn to e4 but now that
he has this he he knows he has to check
at some point so before he does that he
doesn't in between move and that is rook
to c8 he says if I'm gonna play Bishop
to b6 would check I want to have a
discovered attack he's gonna be
attacking this night here on c3 so just
preparing things coming up knowing that
this King here on g1 can be under attack
now pawn to e5 and now decides yeah I'm
gonna go ahead and attack here with
Bishop to b6 yeah sure attack kind of
Knight but I can go ahead and move that
later I'm gonna go ahead and put you in
check so we see King - h1 and now a very
wise move from Rubenstein and you can
imagine is his immortal game one of the
stronger chess players out there you're
gonna see a lot of high-level chess
moves and the first one is Knight to g4
and this is a great deflection you can
see that the Queen can take here on g4
but the Queen's also the sole defender
of the bishop here on d3 and this is a
very critical Bishop in the center of
the board
and so ribbons sign says yeah if you
want to go ahead and take my knight here
I have both of my bishops find
you're King right now that doesn't have
a lot of protection so if you want to do
that that is completely fine so in the
game that's not what we see we see
Bishop here to e4 now if the Queen did
decide to take we have the rook come up
here to d3 and then how does white
really continue maybe rook to d1 then
the Rucka take on c3 Bishop takes where
comes up here to c3 so that's pretty
tough maybe instead after the rook takes
on d3 we see Knight to d1
okay well now rook to c2 and this is the
deadly move right here how does white
actually respond to this maybe rook to
c1 and then Queen to after-work to c1
Queen to h4 and this gets really tricky
from White's perspective as far as how
they actually continue you can see after
the Queen takes here on h4 a Bishop to
g2 with the protection of the rook and
the bishop here on b6 this is going to
be checkmate so you can't do that things
just look extremely bad so in the game
after the knight comes to g4 we do see
the gorge plays at Bishop to g4
Rubenstein's sensing something out there
that he can attack decides to go ahead
and play Queen to h4 and from here pawn
to g3 and this is where things get
pretty interesting because now both of
these bishops are eyeing down all the
critical squares that the King can
actually go to so now that the pawn has
come up here this Bishop is the one
saving piece that White has going for it
this Bishop is not here the game is
essentially over
so Rubinstein knows that he's gonna
spend the rest of the game trying to
attack this square right here now most
players if they look at this pawn to g3
they would say okay my Queens under
attack I'm gonna go ahead and bring my
Queen back here to e7 and not worry
about it but Rubenstein that's not what
he does he recognizes that there's an
opportunity to attack and he plays
takes on c3 now there's a couple ways
for white to respond here if he decides
let's go ahead and take with my bishop
here
he could take bishop on c3 then you see
Bishop takes e4 and this is really tough
to deal with we already know that if the
Queen comes down here this is going to
be checkmate so that's not going to work
right there if instead we see rook to f3
okay well now the bishop takes here
attacking the Queen attacking the King
as well this is just a no way to really
stop this this would be a great mate if
it happened like this because the King
can't take because the knight the Queen
can't take care because it's being
pinned down by the bishop so there's no
real great way to actually respond with
the rook coming up here to c3 now we
have looked at this critical square on
e4 because it's being pinned down by the
bishop on b7 so it does have the option
it could try to take here on b7 and then
the rook comes over here to g3 this pawn
can't move because it's being pinned
down by the Queen things are gonna be
extremely bad as far as what does white
do from here maybe rook to g1 but then
you could just have an exchange here on
a g1 Knight - f - check Queen takes here
Queen takes on F - there's just no real
good way to actually in this black is
gonna have a very good game so after the
rook takes on c3 hey offering up a queen
here I'm gonna go ahead and take that
Queen here on h4 and now the move rook
to d2 and this is another deflection
move because it says hey what are you
gonna do if you take here yeah that's
just a decoy because I'm gonna bring my
Bishop up here to e4 take and then
you're in a world of trouble so what do
you actually do the problem is there's
not many other good moves up for George
to do here so at the end of the day he
actually decides to go ahead and take
here on d2 no other good options
the bishop takes on e4
check and now there's no way to stop
this he has to bring his Queen over here
and now rook to h3 and you can see the
moves keep getting better and better
because he he could easily just take
this Queen here on g2 but he has lost
his his Queen he knows that he's going
for something greater than just getting
that Queen back he plays rook to h3 and
out of all the moves
there's many fantastic moves this is
such a great square because many players
would even feel like yeah I have to go
ahead and take this material back and
then I'll maybe try something with my
knight I'll bring my knight here to e2
i'll fork the king and the rook here
I'll get that rook and maybe I'll have a
good end game but Rubinstein decides
yeah I think I can have a stronger
attack here so he plays rook to h3 and
at this point in the game
his opponent does resign so let's look
at the options as far as how white could
continue one of those would be Bishop to
d4 Bishop takes here on d4 there's no
real good way to continue here rook to
f3 Bishop takes the Queen takes and then
rook up here that is going to be
checkmated we come back a few moves
another option would be look to f3 this
stops it but then the bishop takes
bishop down here just delaying the
inevitable left of the Queen takes the
rook finishes here on h2 and then lastly
we could have rook come to f2 Bishop
takes on f2 the Queen can come down here
but then this is going to be checkmate
as well so after the rook to h3 George
looked at and said yeah good game
there's no way to stop this sacrificing
the Queen and just eyeing all this
material up against his opponent just
too much for him to deal with so that
was Rubenstein's a mortal game fantastic
game always fun to see these epic games
from some of the best players to ever
play the game of chess sacrificing their
pieces using all of the material on the
board to put their opponent in some
really difficult spots and then finding
the best moves even when there's some
really good moves that I think a lot of
people would always look for
but they found something even better and
that's why these games are immortalized
so hopefully you guys enjoyed that video
hopefully you're enjoying some of these
famous games that I'm putting out there
and until next time see you guys then
bye